you played as an action hero
even playing as an anime school girl
you played as an Italian plumber
but have you played everything
pouseylova6
okay so it starts off where you're in a
lil electron or proton or neuron or
think
PFFFT
point to this it's a really a point to
anything hello darkness miles okay
something's happening whoa whoa it's not
a cat I'm a cat I'm what puma or
whatever they're called amazing so we're
playing as a puma right now hello
darkness my old friend oh stop stop stop
stop stop thank you what did they forget
your enemies to get stop stop stop Puma
what is happening what is that stop
robot shop this is not how you walk it's
not how you want
you know I would much rather live in
this world I would much okay here we go
this is just this is the most realistic
rumor simulator game i have ever played
got him oh he's with me now hey mr. up I
don't know what animal you are I'm not
gonna get he's with me now we got a
friend hahaha ok got them hey we're
three now this is amazing you're coming
with that you in the club hey you like
the anti walking at normal animal we got
quite a following ok now we're playing
as a herd of animals that can't walk
straight amazing what is happening Who
am I and why am I here what's happening
out
the disappearing ah we're back with fish
lonely Puma alright alright alright so
you're supposed to be able to control
those those beavers okay here we go I
can't seem to become the beaver but I I
can't become the plan how the fuck would
that work yes yes oh my god damn plan
finally a game that represents Who I
died I identify with driftwood I am a
driftwood everyone i am the best
goddamned refuses that I'm to preferred
treatment oh my god that's crippling
gonna take we gotta take over the
universe join us for a creature dress
boy we will kill know Wow human oh we
got palm trees with the staff the palm
trees enjoyed it remove we will take
over we will take over this planet this
planet will be a armagon agree the trees
and joined suspect
the trees of the way
and do it up
we will conquer the driftwood will come
up hello mr. dear would you like to join
me in my question world domination
excellent follow me this
cheap and they're together forever they
will conquer the universe so if i can
place everything surely then i can play
at the shitty fucking youtuber jacks
bday oh my god we got we must find
Jack's per day hello Rock Joyner the
rocks would not listen but I would not
stop sheep and deer season they're
together forever the Rockland join them
but that would have stopped them oh my
god the rock got deer there ha ha pass
the rocks got me don't come come come
come come to stick I'm coming too thick
calm down how I break it up how do i
send you here please say something ah
Steven cheese together forever together
that will rule the galaxy Darren sheep c
mehta beaver yes i will join you beaver
said and so they went on garen cheap and
beaver Gulf wherever they will want to
go no shit I'm drink to it now yeah damn
it no I don't want to be I don't want to
be fucking driftwood the lime dire hello
talk to smile okay here we go it's an
elk at the fucking alcohol what the fuck
is that sound ah ha ok you can't go
faster damn they're gonna pay
they had a mission to save the planet to
save this planet from Al Gore two
tickets bring the climate change after
of court ain't we find Jack testa cast
that's what they knew they had to use to
save the planet the kind of a sick and
within six bed with shocking please
remember this place remember who you are
Elk didn't understand quick keep in mind
that you called beyond you might need to
find a way back they didn't listen
met another coat but it was we touch
they had who came up with this video
game idea and why now I expected that I
could play as anything but the whole you
didn't tell me about the whole part of
the animals being Satanic beings oh my
god they're tiny baby elks why are they
so small now the elks had a baby they
They were pregnant All along
but this is what I want to do with
myself I just want to make a lot of
babies to then just send them out a date
like an army show that seems like a
viable planet I can make them do old
campus shit 00 together we are thronging
the ghosts have joined it finest yeah
join
china
far pow
where will it end Bieber said what
happened when we're too many and
everyone is with
ok the mission at six
treas men agree with the rocks maybe
again but together we're strong
would you take over this planet but
suddenly they stopped it's like that
Forrest Gump episode when on the sudden
he just stopped running they became a
rock rock is cooking oh the rock take it
over they were searching everything I
put it up why is this again ok I'm
playing at the rock here we go ok I
can't its end what what oh great i'm an
island I'm a goddamn Island now I'm an
island everybody how you doing would you
like to join me other Island ok the
other Island is with me now excellent
great this is great moving across the
ocean this is the best life I have ever
not wanted to live which I can play a
sea grass look I am sea grass now
everybody oh yes I didn't expect to be
seagrass I really wasn't expecting to be
to be seagrass everyone all right well
this is kind of weird I think I'll
switch to I'm a planet I'm apart of
everyone excellent a planet earth let's
crash that fucking shit into the Sun
where is the thing where there's no Sun
great oh there you are ok here we go I
am The Sun I under one down there the
Sun don't sorry I'm sorry I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry ok ok ascend I'm guessing a
galaxy I'm a galaxy I'm a galaxy
everyone oh i ascended the fuck is this
now I'm like microscopic right
whoa whoa what the hell is happening
it's sand green oh it is isn't it what
the fuck we're sand grains can transcend
like oh I'm a clip here whoo yeah boy
yeah we're getting me I can smell that
another bitch and no is closed come on
boy back we're grass now we're fucking
grass all right mushrooms get the
shrimps yeah boy ascend and we're back
with Puma yes amazing no wait so uh
what's that on top of the hill but I see
everything it was everything I ever
wanted and more check out the game in
the description it hasn't actually come
out yet and but I'm very very interested
in it and that definitely will get that
get it when it comes back because I
think it's really cool original fun
concept so props to the developers for
making something really cool and unique
I hope you enjoyed this video if you did
you know what to do and top of the
mornin ok